what's up everyone it's Warren and we
have the official trailer 2 for the
mandalorian tonight I'm still overseas
so my timezone is a little bit different
right now but I stayed up because I'm
really excited to see this trailer so
let's check it out
it's a world more peaceful since a
revolution it is a shame that your
people suffered but bounty hunting is a
complicated process
[Music]
they said you were coming
they said you were the best in the
Parcak would you agree
and then DeLorean
look outside
waiting for you
oh yeah good
well I thought that was awesome that I'm
so excited for this show when it comes
out in less than a month now like a
couple of weeks now and it really just
gonna be awesome jon favreau the whole
entire team that's involved with this
show it's just gonna be amazing that our
team looks better and sorry don't want
to make anybody mad but it looks better
than pretty much any Star Wars movie
that we've seen as of recent that this
looks fantastic Disney does it right
especially with Disney Plus coming out
they're doing all their shows really
really well and I mean that just looks
it looks amazing the Mandalorian looks
amazing like his actual armor and
everything and just the story of the
bounty hunter and how it's supposed to
be about you know kind of like a
Midwestern gunslinger and kind of in the
Star Wars universe is it's it's really
appealing I think and I'm really excited
and looking forward to the show so I'm
gonna be doing breakdowns videos on each
new episode that comes out so be sure to
get your Disney and Plus subscription or
follow along with my channel so you can
stay up to date on everything with the
Mandalorian as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof